two men are facing charges after one of
them tried to steal an airport transport
cart from an employee and now there's a
push
uh in congress to ban booze on airplanes
uh greg let me go to you first this
clearly is an issue for flight
attendants and for pilots and for
passengers
uh but but is is is banning booze the
answer to this to this challenge and
problem that's real
absolutely no
stop blaming booze for the actions of a
few bad eggs we have to admit that we
are in a time of peak stress everyone
from the pilot to the flight attendant
to jesse in 44b
you know everybody's got like maybe a
personal issue at home that's one layer
right that's one layer then you tack on
the artificial pressures of the holidays
that's the second layer then you add
covet that's a third layer you take away
booze that's a fourth layer of
heavy-duty stress we have to understand
that humans are bundles of stress we
need to tread lightly and politely i
would like to call out that i got a nice
little card from delta in the mail that
thanked me for my service or for that
for using them i expected something
other than a thank you but that's okay
but i fly out tomorrow on american
airlines i expect great service by great
people i firmly believe i will not be
reprimanded if my math slips i will be
enjoying a few libations while listening
to my favorite music
and everything's gonna be great
blind american
jesse you're jesse your name was invoked
how do you react to this well i haven't
sat in the 40s for what since my 20s so
get it right gut felt but you can't take
away alcohol in a plane
you have i'd probably rank it this way
you have your shower beer
you have your ski lift chair beer you
have your yacht cocktail and you have
your airline drink it's so and plus it's
medically necessary for a lot of people
to drink alcohol on a flight to relax
their nerves so don't mess with medicine
i would say
the other thing is people would stop
brawling if they dressed better remember
how people used to dress on the airlines
like three-piece suits and dresses now
everyone's wearing sweatsuits yeah
you're gonna rumble in a sweatsuit but
if you look really civilized you're
probably not going to throw haymakers so
just dress nicely and just keep calm
dana you you strike me as someone that
does a lot of what jesse was saying
there do you think that banning booze is
the right thing
oh i wasn't sure in terms of the
brawling or the dressing nicely i think
this is dressing nicely and behaving
politely
i'm tired of being punished
and for things taken away from me
because a few people can't handle things
well i i there was an idea that was
floated that if you get into one of
these brawls at the airport you could be
banned from tsa pre-check and that's
serious i like that you don't want to be
banned from tsa pre-check that's serious
punishment besides harold i think if
they took away booze people would just
take a lot of pills i never took a pill
but i might be tempted
see me afterwards what do you think
about this
well drinking drinking at the airport
and on planes is not new people are
drinking too much because it's the only
thing they're allowed to do without a
mask on so why don't you take away the
mask all the ceos have said it doesn't
do anything on the plane dr fauci wants
you to wear a mask forever if the
federal government lifted the mandate i
guarantee you people would go back to
behaving themselves and drinking less
because it's the only thing you can do
in the airport without having your mask
on and there's only so much you can eat
so
take away the mass and solve this
problem
smart hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else